Hello I'm Right Alicia
and I'm Left Alicia
and this is Fandango Indie Movie Guide
Almost...
Hello everyone!
I have 3 great movies to tell you about today
Let's start with 'Christine'
-Uhh Stephen King?
-No, but just as haunting
*Clip:* Maybe we can go to some footage of the chickens having sex
so people can see how the eggs are really made
That's a joke....
What is this?
What are you doing?
I've just been thinking a lot about your idea of...sensationalizing the news
Christine tells the true story of the final few days of Christine Chubbuck
She's the journalist who killed herself live on air
during a news broadcast in 1974
You see her starting out pretty optimistic
and then slowly becoming more and more disillusioned
as she realise that the network is going for more sensationalize gruesome stuff
that her in-depth local reports
If it bleeds, it leads
Correct! Other Alicia
This is one of those movies where you know where it's going to end
so the whole film is unsettling and tense
as you go towards that inevitable conclusion
*clip* -This people are ruining me...
-This people....
- Won't anyone just listen to me?!
I'm gonna slap a big "awards watch" over this one for Rebecca Hall
because even though is a small film and it might not be able to compete,
when it comes to Oscar campaigning, with some of the other bigger films
I think she definetly deserves and Oscar Nomination for completely inhabiting this role
*clip* -A television first
And now... onto something light
Not really... but this is my pick of the week: 'Tower'
*clip* -There's a guy on top of the tower... and he's shooting, shooting at people!
-We didn't know who was being killed
As you can tell for that clip 'Tower' is a documentary unlike any other
It tells the true story of the first mass school shooting in Austin, Texas
and because this was one of the first, no one knew what was going on. There was so much confusion...
but as with all tragic situations unlikely heroes emerged
and everyday people found strength within themselves
-Sounds quite inspiring...
-It is Alicia! You are correct!
*clip* -There are two different kinds of shots
-The police are returning the fire now
-My mission was to get into the tower
But the way Keith Maitland webs in archival footage with animation of what happened
plus interviews, makes this an absorbing and fascinating film experience
See this in cinemas while you can!
*clip* -I just remember looking up at the sky... It was so blue!
-Just thinking...
I guess this is it!
Those both looked great but... what's out on home entertainment this weekend?
Excellent question! and it's a goodie!
*clip* What we created here made me unique in all human existence
-All the way to the top!
We created paradise
'Captain Fantastic' is film you probably would've heard of if you follow me on Twitter
because I've been going on about this film since January
I saw it at Sundance, and again at Cannes
-Film so nice she watched it twice!
-You could say that
By the way this is what happens when Fandango says I can do anything I want with my show
-She's great!... I love her!
Viggo Mortensen stars as a father who is raising his kids outside of society, in the woods
They are highly intelligent, they are very skilled.
But he realizes when he has to take them back into the modern world
that they don't know how to cope with everyday society, or talk to other teenagers
*clip* - Right now, this is your first real test.
-Remember your train
-They have hotdogs!
-What's "cola"?
-Poison water
The reason why I love this movie so much is that it really makes you think
and it doesn't preach to you, you know. It shows both sides of this
living in society and living out of society
and the prons and cons within it
It's also energetic, funny and very very touching
*clip* -Even if they make it through whatever you're doing to them...
-They are gonna be totally unprepared for the real world!
-And I happen to think the opposite is true..
-It's child abuse...
-That almost hit me!
-If I wanted to hit you, I would've hit you
So, to recap... and let's try to do this one together and really test out my editing skills
In theatres: 'Christine'. Haunting, incredible performance by Rebecca Hall
'Tower': A powerful moving documentary
And at home: 'Captain Fantastic'. It'll make you laugh, it'll make you cry, and it'll make you think
That's it for this episode of Fandango Indie Movie Guide
Let me know below which movies you liked, what you've seen lately
and don't forget you can follow me on Twitter.
I'm Alicia Malone!
and I'm also Alicia Malone!
Bye!